foreign
we've been live for five seconds we're
just all stood there for five seconds
going
to happen
but hello good morning good afternoon
good evening wherever the hell you are
in the world and welcome to um Stargate
Sunday again sorry about that we're
doing it two weeks in a row weather
isn't good I don't think anyone's gonna
complain no might moan a little bit but
um right so hi guys how are you diddling
howdy
I'm going to tease you a little while
with this news by the way just because
Matt you've been bugging me for two days
to go tell me what it is no tell me
no but we'll do the intros and then
we'll crack on
[Music]
okay so hands up who likes Stargate
anybody
oh fans over there
a little bit of everything
yeah exactly so I had an option A couple
of days ago to either do a video on this
or to bring this news live to you guys
first now I decided that one I wanted to
wind YouTube up a little bit
um because winding Matthew up is always
humorous but two
the guys actually come on these live
videos we've got 64 of you right now
that's that's the most you've ever had
kicking off the video that's brilliant
um you guys are the ones that really
have followed us you follow us every
damn week you listen to every damn video
we do you guys deserve to hear this
first
but I'm going to tell you a little bit
of background
a little bit and then I will tell you
what has happened okay
um so two weeks ago and there was a
marketing meeting at MGM and Amazon and
at that marketing meeting
um with one of my sources has been has
allowed me to say that they were
actually sat in on
um which I'm never normally allowed to
say but I'm allowed to say it this time
they were actually sat in on they were
there and they were asked to
um put together a plan for
um basically we're going to announce
Stargate
if we announce a TV series how would you
Market it what are the numbers what are
the things that we that you would do so
what sort of impact can we expect to get
what sort of clicks could we expect etc
etc stuff marketing people do and if we
did a movie what would you do
that marketing report was done just just
under two weeks ago it was delivered to
Jennifer saki Courtney Valentini
um's team on Friday just gone
all right
and they had meetings this Monday so
that's the first bit of big thing that
they had long meetings Michael Wright
was involved briefly but it was mostly
these two people okay so um if you don't
know very quickly Jennifer salkey is the
head of Amazon and MGM Studios and
Courtney Valentini is the new head of
film for MGM and Amazon Studios so
cinematic and streaming movies
all right so that's the first thing
um I then here started hearing a load of
Chinese Whispers And one of the things I
heard was that um and if you've seen the
sides trick sides video I did yesterday
the target update I actually said there
was a rumor
that I didn't believe and I said was
probably not true that a movie was being
announced and it was going to be a hard
reboot now I did hear that was my first
a bit of information I was told that we
were going to get a move and it would be
a hard reboot I didn't say that that's
that's almost certainly not true but
there's some
disagreement about the room I've heard
do you want to know what the actual
rumor oh well actually I'm going to go
far as far as saying this has happened
actually
but I'll explain that to you why in a
minute do you want to know what it is
yes yeah
tell me please
on Tuesday just gone
um Jennifer salkey issued a directive to
um Courtney Valentini in that directive
it talked about the reboot of The
Exorcist and getting Legally Blonde
three back on track
and it said about developing a Stargate
movie
so in the directive
Jennifer salkey has directly issued a
directive to Courtney Valentine's to
begin developing a Stargate movie for
cinematic release
in that cinematic release
um they want filming to start this year
um by late summer Early Autumn
and they want a release for around
winter 2024
and that has actually so I got that
rumor from one person and I said it's
not true I put that on my video
yesterday saying it's not true I didn't
think it was right before I'd actually
after filming that but before putting it
on
I got one other person come to me and
say
this has happened Jennifer salkey's
ordered her to do um to start
development work on the movie
um I then heard from a third Source
yesterday I spoke to a close friend of
the channel but we'll talk about that in
a minute let me come back to that and
then this small uh sorry last evening I
phoned somebody that I know Works um in
the agent side of things and I asked
them to ask around for me they came back
to me within 24 hours saying yes
that's that's accurate
so before we go into a little bit more
detail because I do have a little bit
more
instincts
are we happy it's excited generally that
Something's Happened the ball's rolling
you know
yeah
movie
that's what they've decided
foreign
[Music]
it's not that I'm not happy I am
anything I would be happy with
but there was an ideal situation yes
that would be I don't know for me that
would always have been a TV show but
I guess it depends on which way they go
about it whether it's a hard reboot or
whether it's a continuation or
hybrid kind of thing
it is exciting I I
huh would you like to know the update on
that
yes so they're apparently part of the
directive you know I said I mentioned
about this sg1 revival rather than
anything the working title for the movie
um well well it won't be a working title
for the movie what was put in the
directive was Stargate sg1
this will be a Revival of sg1
um I'm being told that 100 by two of the
three sources anyway told me 100
continuation it is supposed to be an
extension to what we've seen up till now
so not a hard reboot one of the sources
told me hard reboot but the dates I got
told from the different sources were
were off as well slightly so some were
telling me it was going to be a bit
later something a bit earlier but I
think that's just you know like Chinese
Whispers a little bit is as news goes
around people
share it slightly differently but I'm
not really worried about that because
the gist of what they've told me is the
same for everything
it's roughly let's begin filming into
this year cinematic release end of next
year roughly
I just threw my pen on the floor and I
need it that is exciting
that makes me even happier
uh that is lsg1 continuation
I do it though like what are they gonna
what's the story gonna be
I would argue on a simple level
there's just because Dan Daniel and
everyone leaves you're still going to
have an sg1 team man you're still gonna
be the main team
um it's just going to be like well let's
I hope the conversation has been let's
not complicate this you know how you
idiots complicate things we'll finally
get to see Jack and Jack and Sam
together we'll get to see them together
Richard the announcing cameo in it and
then they can do whatever you want with
him but he's gonna come back until they
kill him yeah no don't kill him don't
kill him just let him live don't kill
him
don't get your hopes up
I swear if they kill any of the main the
main the main four
like at all I'll be pissed
there's only one hand yeah the only one
you can kill is Daniel the only one
because he will Ascend and he'll come
back because he always [__] does
okay all right
boy yeah it's not that dead six times
isn't it anyway
um okay so a little bit more
um of the
bit I'm concerned about
oh yeah they've had this directive and
it's gone to
um I've seen it's gone to Courtney
Valentine who's now head of movies for
that there's still no production company
so I was kind of hoping
for this Dimension plant penguin and
Parker it doesn't
um I've also heard a rumor actually that
um Amazon have been talking to Legendary
pictures
potentially about getting involved with
the Stargate project
um they're the guys that recently did
Carnival Row for
um Stargate therefore Amazon Prime
okay so I love personally
um but they're
um they've been around for years and
years and years so that wouldn't bother
but but we always knew there was
potentially going to be another
production company involved but I'm
getting a bit concerned that the whole
penguin and Parker thing seems to be
getting stuck in the mud a little bit
um
so we haven't got those two things
I asked a friend of the channel who
works in the industry you guys know who
I mean but I won't I won't say publicly
just just for the for them sort of thing
but um I asked them is this normal
and they said um to be honest yeah
because
um
they sort of said to me if you if you
think of it if you think of the position
MGM Amazon have been in for the last
eight months and they haven't had a head
they haven't had an executive in charge
of film and it's slow different down
because like we said last week you can't
start announcing projects when you
haven't got the boss in charge because
what if they come in and they don't like
it or then stop messing so you need you
need them on board whatever you decide
to do
so everything's been sort of in limbo
and they actually spoke to me about
Legally Blonde three movie I care
nothing about but this was actually
supposed to go into production during
covid and it's just been
and this is the basically this directive
isn't really anything
it's a right
this has been time you now have
permission to crack on get it done now
we've done all the prep work
everything's been doing this is your
written authorization to do it
so the fact that there isn't a
production company there isn't that
doesn't really matter because that's
kind of Courtney valentini's job anyway
this is the decision has been made this
is what we're doing
we need to crack on with it now now
there's still lots of things that could
go wrong how many films go into the
early development and then we never see
them
well the the trilogy of Stargate films
that Dean Devlin Roman Limerick went
into early development even got green
like they've got green lit and announced
and then never came to be so it happens
it definitely happens yeah it comes all
the time and what's that um there's a
website you can go in and you can see
like all the movies that are currently
in um developments and all the movies
action production like I use it all the
time and I forgot what it's called but
anyway bro all right
um I'll have a look for me but excuse
will be in my uh it'll be my thingies
um
[Music]
but anyway the list of movies that are
in development and have been in
development for bloody years just goes
on and on and on the inside
sorry
Movie Insider
yes that's it inside it yeah um so um I
mean it's just it's just you know it's
this films that are still technically in
development and been on there for like
seven eight nine years it's just like
just goes on and on but anyway
um
so this is
my point really is this is why this is
so exciting is this for what the
decision has been made and it's actually
been that memo whatever you want to call
it to say
yeah permission
let's do this let's get on with it
um like I said a little few things issue
there so like I say anyway this big
person I spoke to certainly yeah that
makes perfect sense this is directive
this is my decisions made and that's
what actually Mark Fergus has been
screaming about I've been on for about
three or four months now he's just been
saying well you just will you tell me
what we're doing
am I doing a film or am I doing a series
just just tell me that that's a basic
yeah yeah you know now I know right
is it's been done at the decisions made
now this whole marketing thing that I
mentioned earlier on that was just that
that was apparently like the last step
so that was like the cherry on the cake
this is the right okay we need to make a
decision we want the numbers so they
went the marketing team they got them
the numbers they looked at it and they
made that final decision but we know I
mean I I've had rumors from Jennifer
sulky that she's wanted to do a movie
for a long time but that's what she felt
was right but let's talk about the pros
and cons of a movie because I have seen
some of the messages
going past sorry guys I can't read
things so um I think the main con that
people are gonna bring up is if it bombs
does that kill does it kill the TV
series almost certainly yeah
that's just that's what I'm worried
about
I
guess as exciting as it is to have any
Stargate back we want it to succeed
because we wanted to go on another 10 20
years
yep
what do you think about that looks like
well we had a disagreement video last
week where we we picked two sides of the
argument and I got panned you know
because I picked movie I didn't pick a
movie we sort of just said well one of
us got new TV One's got a movie I did a
little bit at the end I got loads
I gave you the Short Straw because I
just went yeah I like your TV show and
you went all right then
um
no you're wrong you're wrong Jay you're
wrong and then they watch my bits at the
end of the credit score I go
don't tell anyone don't do it maybe
forever got out of the movie
um and they went ah you're right so
anyway
um but I then put a poll on who who
wants a movie first she wants a TV
series first and it was like it was like
80 to something last time I looked
um over a thousand votes as well so yeah
loads loads of votes and we'll have a
quick look while we're talking but is
that
what risk do we have with that do you
think though that because I mean that's
how traditionally new TV shows
franchises whatever however you want to
call it started that started with a
movie The only thing I'm a bit a little
bit worried about that I don't quite get
is their point on the cinema
but that can change to be honest that
changes all the time I mean prey was
going to be on the cinema and then the
Hulu pulled it last minute and decided
now let's just put it on streaming
um and and some film like a police was
supposed to be streaming and they've
gone the other way and they've said no
no actually let's put this on Cinema so
I mean they can change that but
yeah
is that the only risk for the movie The
Financial
kind of it just depends on what route
they take like if it depends on who they
put in it how many people they put in it
is it mostly old cast mostly new cast a
good like amalgamation of the two what
are we talking and I guess we're just
gonna have to find out yeah
um
who's in it and who's going to be
centered around is going to be a big
thing because if they do an entirely new
cast and no one that we know has been in
it but no one for pre from previous
Stargate is in it even once
then is it Stargate
there is that so there's 1100 votes
um Stargate should return with a movie
or TV series 22 said movie 78 said TV
series that's pretty
that's kind of telling that's that's
there I think I think next week I'm
gonna make a video on my actual thoughts
about this uh because I'm gonna I want
to sit on it for a week and figure out
exactly how I feel about it because
because you've only just told me and
honestly I
I don't know how to feel so I'm going to
Stew on it for about for about a week so
next week that'll be my video
um but anything that comes to me now
will obviously I'll say well I wanted to
drop it on you but now actually
realizing I probably should have told
you before and so you could put your
thoughts together but I was dropping
someone to see your faces really but um
I I think there's a few risks to a movie
well disappointment things about a movie
for one it's going to take longer to get
on our screens sort of thing yeah it'll
instead of we could have this in 12
months a series instead we're gonna have
two years
but one hand I think I always compare
Stargate to Star Trek right so I always
think Star Trek is what from a
production value at least we want to aim
for that's the sort of money we want per
episode that's the sort of impact we
want that's great that's what we we want
people talking about it like people talk
about Trek that sort of thing we don't
necessarily want the stories that track
keeps throwing at us but we want the
impact sort of thing
so
um Star Trek have basically Jonathan
Franks has come out and said look we're
not doing any more movies
we're not doing it the future for Star
Trek is television
but Amazon think Stargate can have a
cinematic movie I actually sort of think
that gives us sort of bragging rights if
if this was a Gators versus trekkies
argument I'm not like going we got a
movie you ain't got a movie
nah something
I agree with you there that makes sense
just because
it is it's worth bragging about I mean I
thought it was childish
well it's been gone for so long and
sleeping China sci-fi I almost wore that
shirt today I should have worn that
shirt today uh because if it's just
leaving giant if it can come back and
Studio still think well let's do a movie
over a TV show even with us all they
know how much we all want a TV show they
do I mean they're looking at that poll
they've talked about Sidetrack they've
talked about all these different
channels talk about uh Stargate in
general they know what we want
and they're still going forward with the
movie that means they have to be
confident in what they have right I
would hope I would think
that might just be dumb optimism but I'm
keeping my face across because like they
might they probably have some sort of a
plan for movie uh and then some sort of
series to follow on maybe they're doing
it kind of like we're
uh I I I I'm not going to purchase to
Star Trek because I'm not a massive fan
but like Star Wars for example there was
the three the three movies whatever you
think about them they did quite well
financially
and then you've got then you've got all
the series come out after that which it
appears like all the old fans and stuff
maybe they're going to do a similar kind
of thing
potentially
yeah maybe so it's the same universe
it's the same story but it's gonna be
and then on that vein hopefully the
series that we get will be of the same a
similar quality like it will feel like a
movie when you're watching it it won't
feel like a
TV show from the 90s it will feel it'll
feel epic that's
something I'm I'm hoping if you answer a
question that popped up in the thing is
this actually been announced no but um
that's the other thing that I think when
would it get announced
um
basically again I spoke to a friend of
the John
um and I just said when do you think
Amazon would announce this and he says
it depends
right so like Amazon like to announce
things when everything is set up but
basically as soon as they've got the
main actor signed on
and they've got a script that they're
reasonably happy with
it'll go announced
so
the problem is we don't necessarily know
the full story I think it's weird that
we that they've gone as far as this
and don't have a script
um
but we don't know necessarily they don't
have script
and the one of the things that's a
friend of the Channel that I spoke to
that you guys know I'm talking about um
did say was unless they are going to go
with something that they've had
previously so it would be I was just
about to say that Brad script script
script
yeah um or a version of brand script or
something in Roland I don't I don't want
to say that and then again people's
hopes up yeah
to be honest yeah
but I think it's more likely they don't
have a script and they don't have a
production company and this is just
the boss making the decision
well didn't Bad Robot script get canned
because Bad Robot have that deal with
Warner Brothers and they have to adhere
to it they can't do anything else at the
moment they can't do anything bad robot
can't do anything why they've still got
that deal
yeah so that means they're out
incredibly unlikely and as far as we
know they didn't actually go as far as
writing a script they only did the
summary they only did like a pitch
summary they never made me think of
something
Bad Robot can do other things kind of
right because didn't their Batman cake
Crusader series that was supposed to go
on HBO Max that HBO said we're not going
to put on is now going to Amazon
but it's still being done with the
Warner Brothers uh Warner Brothers are
making the show so the only way they
could do that is if Warner Brothers made
Stargate for Amazon okay okay I could do
that they could they could do a deal
with Warner Brothers to co-produce and
they have done other things
um I saw so I saw something really
recently and I was surprised it's Warner
Brothers and it was on Amazon
what was it
'll come to me in a minute but um but
yeah um but like Warner Brothers made I
watched I went to the cinema yesterday
and watched what did I watched the
semester
65 no no okay the other one
it was literally yesterday
um I'm too over excited about this video
but anyway that was Warner Brothers in
in cooperation with somebody else and I
was surprised I was like Warner Brothers
um this is MGM oh that was it Creed
Creed Three
um
between Warner Brothers and MGM so I
know MGM is obviously owned by I think I
mean that that film started Production
Way before the sale went through but
um and obviously Creed one and two were
also percent of Warner Brothers but but
they have a working relationship was my
point so they could
and they could go that way I don't
expect them to but if they want to do a
little HBO route and kind of get some of
their people that do like House of the
dragon or Game of Thrones type stuff in
there come on give us that quality
Stargate I wouldn't complain
MGM and Warner Brothers doing having a
partnership on a project like this that
would make perfect sense because one
brother's own one of the largest Studio
complexes
in the state and that's the big problem
MGM Amazon have that they don't
so this is why they need them the
production companies they need somebody
that actually owns real estate to
actually make the band thing
um
but but yeah
says you had trouble recording film you
saw in theaters yesterday all right I'm
45 years old
I've eaten I've slept twice since then
actually because I've only met this
afternoon because I woke up awful mood
this morning
um I actually apologize to my wife I
sort of rolled over I'm in a really crap
mood and and I'm going to get angry at
people and I'm apologizing advance so
she's like go to sleep go to bed
so I've slept twice since then
um yeah
[Music]
um
my first thought though was
Brad Wright's script it's Matthew
Gunston there we go he's back
um oh my internet's running low sorry
guys I might Stitch it a little bit
um
the you froze my enemy but yeah my first
thought was quite script Brad script to
be turned into a movie
I did think that
yeah
they they must know how how many
people how many thousands of people are
begging for Brad
even though
people who watch this channel I know a
lot of them still want brag but they've
come with considered you know the
acceptance of
it probably won't happen
there are still people there's there's
hundreds of thousands of Stargate fans
who have never seen us before who are
still in the camp of we want Brad
I mean because like gateworld and dial
the gate still are
yeah they won't they won't let it go
yeah because
I mean I think it makes it would make
sense for them to do it I mean
why
it would cost them more money
essentially to hire someone else to make
and to make an entirely new script to
come up with a whole new idea why not go
with something that already exists work
work on it potentially make it a little
bit better than well it was but
just well that's the thing they can take
the script and credit Brad as a writer
for the entire thing and they can Market
it as Brad writes back with Stargate but
they could have a whole new Rider
literally take his story plot for plot
and just rework it into
something that doesn't sound so Brad
right like or whatever is holding back
Amazon from using Brad they can kind of
hire somebody else to work around that
while still using his plot for plot
story if they want to
there's two reasons why I I'm pretty
sure
after all the conversations over 18
months and I've had because I mean
obviously in the rumor no Brad
two or three months after starting
Sidetrack so I mean it was 13 14 months
ago I started hearing that they weren't
going to go with Brad that Amazon didn't
like the story but the two things I
heard basically was
very early on they just didn't like
the the script they just didn't like it
they just didn't like it no no it was
badly written or anything like that but
it was just like they didn't like the
direction he wanted to take it
um I don't quite know why but a couple
of those voices
um were there and a couple of voices at
MGM as well but the one guy was more
pressured because he just didn't want
Stargate to come back but he's left now
um so
um
the other reason though that they didn't
want to go with Brad is because that's
how not that's just not how Amazon do
business they go with production
companies so they need a company that
are going to make this for them Brad
Wright doesn't own a production company
um MGM did it with Brad back in the day
and mg and Brad then created a
production company that then produced a
TV show and they basically
he had one he called it like
yeah two or three in the end
it was like kawush Productions or
something wasn't it yeah yeah well it
started sg1 started with gecko which was
actually Richard Dean Anderson and
Greenberg I don't even know who
Greenberg was but but they started the
production and they they sort of were
the main production company and then
that moved into whatever Brads was and
then for Stargate University had a
different one again
um and I planned said before again but
anyway
um but they then rented a studio in in
Canada and that's how they did it
um the thing is that's not how TV shows
get made anymore
so it will be
um and there's also you've got to
remember that they want to go into a
franchise Brad I couldn't do that from a
production company he couldn't
potentially have
a movie maybe a couple of TV series
somewhere else on the Go at once you
just couldn't it'd be impossible
um but they could potentially buy the
script off of him
they own the script oh yeah
The Graduate script is owned by MGM
they've paid Brad Wright to create a
script for them
so they could still use it and still
have him as the as the writer you get
this all the time it um scripts are
taken from a writer
um I remember Kevin Smith wrote um
script Superman
um years ago the um and it ended up
being the um the Roth one
um
movie right it would have been the Nick
Cage movie yeah eventually it became
um Superman
um yeah and
um and Kevin Smith is very clear about
he says the one thing they basically
kept my plot and removed all of the
actual like words and redid All the the
verbal stuff and he says that's weird
because that's the thing I'm good at
because I'm rubbish at the plot and
stuff I'm good at the like people
talking
um you know I said but he didn't have
any any Authority on that
um he says like they kept one line and
he says he hated the line and nearly
didn't put it in and it's the one line
they kept
um but he generally he doesn't even get
credit for it though because they own
the script they bought a script off him
they gave it to somebody else to
completely redo and yeah they they MGM
could very easily do that with Brad
right script if they wanted to
the unit guys remember like last year we
kept talking about were those two
scripts on the go at one point so there
was Brad right this was back when MGM
still thought they were actually going
to be allowed to make whatever they
wanted and they were going to still be
allowed to exist as a company
and then they quickly found out that
they weren't but they they had a second
script and they were seriously looking
at it and um I've heard since it was
probably a Dean devil in script that was
written four or five years earlier
somebody literally just pulled it out of
a bag somewhere I went
let's do this to compare and contrast
and get a few ideas going sort of think
this big book
sorry that would have been a hard reboot
because that's what's more than likely
have been the second movie in their
Trilogy they were planning
like we knew bits about that script and
it didn't
it wasn't hard because Daniel Jackson oh
no actually to be fair we don't know but
um
it was it was vague enough that we can't
be certain but it didn't sound like a
hard reboot but I was told that Dean
Devlin was asked to produce something
um between the movie and between Brad so
it would have been about 2018.
um so it might have been a
thing but he was just asked to do that
it wouldn't necessarily been anything to
do with roller Denmark if you get me so
we don't know but that's the one that I
said I've actually I actually saw the
first bits off and it was yeah gone
through the gate and equally keeping
voices Daniel his voices and then it
looks like it's like I was just thinking
about that when when that video came out
we're thinking oh the voicelessness had
his own madasala if it was a dean devil
inscription it was a hard reboot it's
completely it wouldn't be would it be
some other entity we've just attached
what we already know to it
it's actually going to be something else
yeah we assumed it was Daniel Jackson we
assumed it was Michael Shanks as Daniel
Jackson but it could have been James
Spade as Daniel Jackson
we don't know
um but we assumed but anyway
um
I I'm just trying to think there's
anything else I was supposed to know
oh the one thing apparently sulky has
said
um I asked about the time frame I said
was like two years I mean that's like
they're gonna start filming within six
months is that doable
and if they haven't got a script and
they haven't got a production company
and um the guy I spoke to said and
they've been working on this for two
years they've got loads of material to
to lean on so whoever comes in isn't
going to be hitting it flat they've got
a load of stuff to back to to work on
you know because they'll get a script
done in
a couple of months
that they're not worried he just says
that they could they could easily get
something like this going because if it
was a completely new project and they
were completely coming out of it cold
six months is tough but they're not
you've got to think of it this has been
two years in development already and in
different level you know early
development sort of thing so
it says he reckons I say this guy he's
not he doesn't work for MGM or things
this guy was talking to Works actually
4am
quite small production company they
actually make movies
um I've already said more than I should
actually be first I showed up now but he
actually does this for a living and he
was saying now six week and weeks about
that six months if we've got enough
development work if you've got a script
you can go from
um the directive from your boss to
filming in three months
not if it's a big sci-fi but for most
films you can go you can get going
really fast
I mean if they have a really good
dedicated team that knows at least the
general story and project that they want
to do look at Iron Man back in 2008 they
were literally writing the script day in
day out like they didn't have a script
and I mean thankfully John Favreau was
John Favreau and they had a good Kevin
foggy team to back that up but
hey you got a good crew in there and if
you get people that know the project
they want to do it's possible that just
happen all the time with old Network TV
shows though
um that they would literally go in and
start filming and in the Next Room
there's a load of guys who can typing
like crazy
um
because they were doing like 22 Episodes
12 months they were filming for like 18
hours a day and sometimes they'll be
like how are we going to end this and
you could see that sometimes in series
because they sort of write themselves
into corners and then you're like oh my
God wouldn't it Star Trek particularly
TNG was terrible for this they'd write
themselves into a corner and God this is
amazing dramatic you know finale I think
how are we going to get out of it and
you're like well that's tomorrow's
problem and then they'd have this like
really lame way of getting out of it
inside yeah
um they used to do it all the time
um but they don't I don't think they do
that so much anymore even though I keep
watching Picard season three at the
moment that I'm loving
but I I do keep saying that like oh my
God there's a lot of script errors in
this series and continuity errors and
stuff but um you do wonder they seem to
be writing that as they go along and
changing their minds as they go along
it may be
yeah maybe
um
so this is what we'll game well it looks
like they've made the decision we're
getting a movie
what is the ideal
for this then because I mean yes she has
basically said we want to do this movie
now but again we only know a snippet in
that picture we basically know that
because that's that's got out in the
people that work here and the basically
the reason why people that I speak to
know is because like agents and stuff
are like sniffing a contract
and um I actually spoke to somebody else
and they're saying it's it is
um a zoo at the moment in in Hollywood
because streaming service is a slowing
down
um we've just had the Oscars everybody's
out there going for contracts that
there's one contract there's one you
know everyone's going nuts like trying
to find the next big thing
um uh it says it is it's a madhouse at
the moment in Hollywood more than usual
um so that's why this has got like
people you know there's blood in the
water and the sharks are going how can
we make money on this
um
but what is the ideal because if they're
just going to announce a movie
I may be a little nervous
what if they announce a movie and
see at least one season of something
immediately followed
does that change that would be good
because
but at least for me
no if I knew there was a series coming
directly afterwards or maybe like a year
after something like that maybe
um
the movie doesn't really have to answer
that all that many questions
it could just be a good movie
this series could then answer the
questions that have been burning in our
minds for the past
10 years 11 12 years
the movie could
could be
I don't know the aftermath of
some big big thing that we hadn't seen
and then the series could be going back
to to view that um I think it could be
it could be like going back to say
Destiny said the crew of Destiny or
something in Pegasus Galaxy or it could
be anything like the the universe is so
huge the story the potential for stories
is insane but the movie doesn't if there
was something coming afterwards the
movie doesn't necessarily have to
deliver on everything yeah
so
it could just be a good movie and that
would be fine
and that would being a good movie
get more people to watch it more people
will then be like oh let's go watch the
series that comes after it and then they
go hang on what's this based on and they
might watch the previous series as well
and then we get more Target fans Harris
Why do you think then if you if you put
your executive brain on rather than
Stargate fan brain why do you think
they're playing with a movie rather than
a series
well like well it has to be a good movie
right but I I think probably their
mindset is that it's got to be yes it's
gonna be good it doesn't have to over
complicate itself necessarily but it's
got to be a big movie One Way or Another
the movie has to end in a big fashion of
some sort because that ending will be
the Catalyst to whatever series comes or
whatever multitude of series comes uh
and it has to be a strong enough
Catalyst to get people to watch the show
and then stay invested in the show and
be a good enough plot device for
whatever happens in the show
uh and and that's probably where they're
struggling that's probably where the
Hang Up is I'd assume it's just like how
do you end something that
you want people to come back to but they
haven't seen in the past 10 15 20 years
and just been they have these different
expectations and of course you have to
meet those but I think
an ending's hard to land if you have
certain expectations to meet and they
have a lot of expectations to meet uh so
hopefully they're
thinking about it and make it big make
it worth coming back to or more than
just us people that are going to watch
it no matter what
uh I think if they have a plan if they
have a plan so they know they're doing a
movie but if they have a plan for what's
going to happen next that can influence
the end of the movie and then it could
be good
rather than going into it
as a movie anything how can we make this
movie End in an epic fashion without
really putting much thought into what
comes next it needs it needs to be the
other way for sure and they have to have
at least a decent sized name a fairly
big name that that's a new name it's
gonna be of course the face of the
franchise we all know that but is it
gonna be Mouse teller is it gonna be who
how do they incorporate that is Miles
Teller gonna be a new character is he
going to be the older version of the
O'Neill clone you could there's all
types of things to do
I don't know we could jokingly of course
always just get Tom Cruise to play uh
Jack O'Neill he could just add another
Jack character and put Miles Teller in
there and that's that's money right
there so
yeah no listen to me Jack
he was he's played four different Jack
characters he doesn't need another
I'm I'm wondering
if only fish that was in this game
mattress and we've also got his name
Courtney Valenti and thing and I know
there's all this work and
um certain actors have been approached
and
um we know this Miles Teller was
potentially sounded out about would you
be interested we know that
um uh David Blues apparently sounded out
and as was
um
thank you
um Russia is hand sanded that as well
um I I hear that Michael Shanks Amanda
Tapping
um Christopher Judge would come back in
a heartbeat I think we know that
um and apparently there have been some
some conversations be made
because apparently that was penguin and
Parker doing that they were sort of
sounding people I'm just like would you
be interested and I think it's almost a
way very early on a production sort of
for them to get their thinking of what
we're going to do okay if we were to do
this What actors can we get because if
we can't get them we can't do it and
blah blah blah but anyway
very early conversations were done
I'm wondering if this is a
Clean Slate now
and and would that be a problem but all
these rumors and all these conversations
that we've heard
none of those who involve Courtney
Valentini
because she's new to the job she started
March 1st
um
none of these were done around the
decision was made that would definitely
go in movie so at this point penguin and
Parker are trying to have plans and
maybe putting feelers out when they
don't really know what they're doing now
they know what they're doing
now they know it's okay we're doing a
movie does that maybe go
okay anything we were thinking before
out the window we need to start again
because now now we know what we're doing
sort of things that make sense
yeah I don't see them tossing everything
out though
but yeah I can't
I can't see them if they've already put
the work in like trying to see who's
already interested I can't then see them
then going back on it just because she's
new in the job
I don't really think means that much
because you start a new job and
whoever your predecessor was they would
have put a little bit of work and you're
gonna have to finish their work you
always have to finish the previous
person's job
about what it is so
I think I think in this respect that
there's nobody in the job for like eight
months
so everything was just sort of like I
mean Jennifer salkey stepped in and did
some of the bits and Bobs uh yeah well
no one was in the job but there were
other people doing the job
um there would have been for someone
some some lower level or something like
stepping up to try and fill in the fill
in the role
yeah I'll do do some of the work and
this this would have been some of the
work
I think they were they've been treading
water for eight months to his respect
somebody would have had to step in
because there were still films coming
out but no new big projects have been
announced because
they've just been treading water and
like I said the Legally Blonde was the
example it was given to me and is that
this has been like I said this was
supposed to be filming two years ago and
they still want to do it and Reese
Witherspoon is still on board to do it
um and it'll it'll it'll do well
probably I'm not watching it but it'll
probably do well
um and they they're having to sort of go
all right enough messing around now do
it
something and that now we can do now
with the management teams in order crack
on and I think it's the same with
Stargate it's been treading water for
two years two
and now something I worry about let's do
it with something I do worry about with
a movie
they do like bringing things back for
nostalgic reasons Legally Blonde three
would be a Nostalgia thing yeah it'll be
massively nostalgic
I don't really want them to do that with
stock I don't want it to be a Nostalgia
trip I want it to be
as if nothing had ever happened
as if the last 15 years of not nothing
hadn't happened I just want it to be a
good movie I don't want it to be a look
down memory lane kind of thing and oh
look this is a
this is that character you knew 20 years
ago
like just make a good movie when they do
that in films you know when they do the
scene it'll just they just at MGM and
I'm sorry marvelous stuff do all the
time and they'll do a scene that's just
for the fans to go
look at him he's here and actually
doesn't add anything to the story I hate
it when they do that
people who don't necessarily understand
the previous iteration of whatever
property it is we'll just be like well
what does that mean and then there's
always the people like oh it means this
it means that's Thor I thought was an
Asgard yes he was a little green a
little gray alien yes he's dead now but
um
thank you
a whole stream doing that voice
you're a whole stranger the rest of the
stream yeah I'll scream at this voice
um I I think that um
for me
the only thing that ever concerns me
when they've got a project like like
anything big anything is is when they
don't have a clear Direction I think
that's when things go wrong so TV series
movie I would prefer a TV series I think
it's less risky and it would go in our
screen sooner and I'm greedy so I went
now and
um you know and I and I actually think I
want 10 hours of Television I don't want
two hour movie and then wait another
bloody 12 Monster Series I want it I
want it now so that's just me that's
what I want
but I can see the thing of doing a movie
that then has a big impact and kick
starts to franchise I get it
um
I just wonder though
um where my point was because I've
forgot an halfway through that sentence
what did I start this film you watched
yesterday and you can't remember the
sentence you started like 20 seconds ago
it'll come back to me in a few minutes
so as soon as I go oh I got the point
now I got the point anyway
live stream so what you can do
um
no but
no it's completely gone well the
Nostalgia bait that Joe were just
talking about like that that was it yeah
okay
um
with streaming services nowadays because
we've watched all this stuff and we've
said this the last couple of times in
videos
um that maybe they're they're more
likely to actually just give us a good
story that actually links in with what
we've seen previously because because of
streaming platforms people can go back
and watch it and people do watch it more
regularly instead of it back on the
networks people could go years without
even being able to watch the repeat of
something well now you can just watch it
whenever you want
so we could get a story that's more
connected to sg1 than we ever thought
was possible because it wasn't five
years ago just wasn't possible
or we could get a Bad Robot and I'm not
a bad driver but I'm going to do it but
a Bad Robot sort of what they did with
Star Trek movie where it's an
entertaining action movie that really
isn't that connected to the franchise
but isn't entertaining movie just to
kick things off and then we'll go into a
series
but and I'm at this point now because I
don't think that makes sense because
they keep talking about wanting to
Kickstart a franchise
and if you're kickstarting a franchise
you're not going to disconnect the movie
to the series I mean even Star Wars
connect their movies to the series now
quite a lot they're very into mixed with
each other
um in style if nothing else
if they're kicking off a franchise that
movie cannot be just a standalone film
can it
no it has to
it has to
lead on to something yeah it has to
connect from what's been and it has to
connect what's going to come
yeah yeah
it's good yeah it's got to because it's
got It's like it's like
the Marvel Marvel is a better a good
example of all of this because
they're good Standalone movies but they
all connect and there's a big story that
they're basically all I'm not going to
talk about phase what we're in phase
four phase five
yeah so everything up to lead up to
phase four up to end game
yeah it was all they're all very good
Standalone stories but they were leading
up to end game or yeah
um the one before that comment well
that's called Infinity War
and then end game
yeah I just think it has to it has to
have it has to connect
well it has to mean something
the good thing about Stargate is they
can do a lot of that kind of work with
the series instead of having to because
I mean that Marvel had series I guess
but at first their television wasn't
truly connected to their movies and now
you know they are but it's a whole
Disney plus thing that's a different
animal
but
they have the potential to use a series
to slowly trickle in some of the
Nostalgia instead of because I I do
worry about that in a movie it's just
like maybe the whole movie might not be
too Nostalgia baby but the whole First
Act might end up just oh let's go back
and meet this guy let's grab her let's
do this grab these aliens like and then
you get the story started we don't need
a First Act that's not gonna actually
Propel a story
they could do that I I joked about uh
Top Gun Miles Taylor and Tom Cruise a
minute ago that was the best way to do
Nostalgia bait that first scene with Tom
Cruise you get the Top Gun song you get
them on a motorcycle you watch some cool
stuff one scene done and then you're
into the movie and it's it gets it's
that's the tone it does everything it
needs to I don't know exactly how you
work around that with the multitude of
characters but there's there's a way to
do it organically it just has to feel
organic without slowing down everything
and without I guess
take taken opportunity because if you
just toss everybody in there it does
take opportunities from the series to oh
you have to watch this episode now like
we do in the Mandalorian like some other
character comes in from the comics or
from the television shows like Clone
Wars or something like that you freak
out oh CAD Baines and book of Boba Fett
book of Boba Fett wasn't all that great
but Imma watch it if cat Bane's in it
you know
so on so forth with Stargate just add
tilk in there in an episode add Samantha
Carter and the end of the movie instead
of the beginning like put them in the
places where they need to be and not
where we we'd like them to be yeah yeah
put them into put them in the story
where it makes sense not just shoehorn
them in for the sake of shooting them in
yeah exactly which in the past is what
they used to do isn't it in the past it
was a character returned and they were
just there to go oh look it's me yeah
and
um and the reason for them being there a
lot of the time was vague to say the
least it was I'm just walking around the
background I've got lost in the base and
I'm here now hello
um something
um everything Jeff Goldblum comes back
and does as much as I love Jeff Goldblum
why is he in the new Jurassic World
movies and he didn't need to be an
Independence Day Resurgence of them well
the forest Kelly was in the opening the
um episode of Star Trek the Next
Generation that came back and he was
just literally putting loads of old
man-made a couple he was supposed to be
about 190 years old and he was just
chatting with data walking down a
corridor no reason for it it wasn't
there for any other reason than a
30-second oh it's an Enterprise I like
the Enterprise bye there was no reason
for it it was just to come here just
because he was free available right
um if but if they do an sg1 Revival I
think they've got to throw in little
characters you know if they don't have
oh his name's his name's come out in the
head and I'm gonna get yelled at I'm
having a bad day man I'm so my brain's
quiet today just everyone sticks encoded
Chevron 7 encoded Walter Walter
I'm having a bad day my brain's not with
me today
um
if they've got to throw Walter in there
he doesn't have to be in every episode
but if he's not in at least one
you know
and then we don't we can forget about
him we're not see him again we're not
bothered but Sergeant Siler just have
him
randomly like the gate I don't know the
gate's broken and he just appears he was
like and then because he's a good man
you can blow him up
yeah
so
um if you don't know the story the guy
that played side or was actually a stunt
man and he was he was just always doing
the stunts early on but he he was in
them so many he just eventually became a
regular character by accident he just
sort of like from ground and then he
became it he got a speaking Parts but
he's actually a stunner
um but anyway
um
the thing that worries me if with with
the if they do a cameo what I don't want
them to do is it happens in movies a lot
it happens more so in TV shows but in in
movies like a character will walk into
the screen walk into the shop and then
they'll pause because they know in the
cinema people are going to be like ah
and like I don't want that I just just
make like yes we can get excited about a
character on the screen but don't don't
make it so obvious that they walk in and
pause for you to react don't bloody do
that it's stupid
so I I'm Devin's Advocate right there
what are you gonna do if they say a
really important line and everybody's
too busy cheering then you're pissed off
you didn't hear the line
oh the person in front of me if they're
if they're screaming their head off I
will slap them I'm trying to watch the
film We're British we don't do that
Americans You're Gonna Miss after the
movie yeah
that's a massive like thing of emotion
that is that's just like that's just
that's just exploding in the motion
if someone has uh rustly like crinkly
crisps or something in the cinema yeah
if they're making any noise
we will we will like hit not what we
were the first thing is not going to be
hit you but we will tell you to shut up
and then we'll call the same thing
generally speak the British Rock Town
somebody shut up but British will do is
we will touch and we will sigh and we
will stare at them with hatred and not
say no we'll go we'll just go
kick the back of their chair so the
popcorn falls on the floor yeah
I've said this on a live before but I
was in cinema once watching a movie and
a guy answered the phone and started
talking and but he was talking like a
normal volume and it says you've never
you've never had like so many people
hate one person in your life
he was yelled at yeah
how many Cinema
yeah yeah Harris don't know what that is
but yeah basically that's what I did he
actually said I'm in the cinema
and then started talking we were like it
pulls out a massive massive phone like
this big
again Harris has got no no clue what
you're talking about but um
so guys I mean that's
that that's really the big announcement
and that's really the thing that
I'm hoping they're doing like they have
a plan a hope to do a marvel-esque
movies series
games and they're gonna you know the
storyboard together and this is just the
way they're kick-starting
um
but a TV series and then a movie
if it was planned right
well now we're saying that they're going
to do a movie first I think the decision
you know what I think the only reason
that they've made this decision to do a
Stargate movie first is because
um Amazon have decided that they're
going to put a crapload of money aside
every year to do cinematic releases
and Jennifer salkey is gone well let's
use some of that money for Stargate and
that's that's why this has been this is
why this happened right it's literally
the money's there and they're doing it I
work for the council I know this is how
managers think
and there's opportunity
I don't blame them for taking the
opportunity yeah but at the same time
like you just said Marvel
that's what they've been doing for the
last couple years and that's how they've
lost all their credibility
that's that does worry me a little bit
because I mean we have talked and joked
about oh we could have two series we
could have a mini series here we could
have a mini series here and I'm down for
all that but it has to be pertinent and
it has to
tell I mean you can tell a one-off story
and not have it correlate to things but
make sure it's good and
and not just for the sake of doing
something I guess
the thing is though with that I don't
think Stargate particularly not coming
back it's not a big enough franchise for
them to just Star Wars right they Disney
are just going we have to have three
series of something every year we have
to have a movie every so many years and
this has to be done right this and we
don't we almost don't care what you do
but there's got to be something Star
Wars on our screens Stargate isn't big
enough for that they're going to be more
we're telling a story I can't see Amazon
go in you have to do this this and this
because they'll just go well we haven't
got a story you know what I mean you you
can't just attach stargate's name to
something and people will watch it like
you can with Star Wars
so I mean anything with Star Wars that
would that would more than likely come
later on after they've been built and
established accessible yeah I worry
about that in two three years even just
if it is successful if it's first season
or two other shows successful that they
don't just start jumping the gun you
know
I mean Star Wars Mandalorian you get
season one season two let's do book of
Boba Fett real quick instead of actually
focusing on Mandalorian three we'll put
that out in two and a half three years
instead
that didn't turn out all that well
um
for those two episodes
on 2.5 for those two episodes it's great
this is season four of mandatory
technically if you have those two
episodes in the book above it was season
three and I think yeah
um
but yeah I mean
the other thing is though I honestly
think the streaming services are slowing
down
um
but
they're still Amazon is still pushing
because they they want to push MGM plus
they've sent all this money they want to
push it and bond is going to be a big
deal they're going to be there's
apparently going to be a bond television
series as well streaming series
um
apparently
[Music]
um
yeah
um did I not mention that
yeah no and that's the rumor that I've
heard that they want to do a but it
won't be Bond it'll be one of the
characters so it'd be like a Q Series
I thought they were going to do like
young ones or was that the is that the
movie
the point of the movie they're going to
do a reboot and apparently the plan is
to go with a younger actor and it'll be
a pre-think but that keeps getting
kicked around they can't make their
minds of what they're doing but again
this is bond is the next thing this this
is Courtney Valentin he was also given
the directorate about Bond apparently
but I don't know what it was
and the stone thing was said about Bond
last week
um but again it's I think it's just like
the car's been wandering around a little
bit Jennifer sulky sort of gone right
we're doing this this and this get the
car going get get us straight on the
road now Bond get it going we need to we
need to make some decisions we need to
crack on Stargate metal stunt you know
what I mean this is what this director
is about it's like right this is our
goal for the next 12 months this is this
is the sort of time frame we want
um as I say no bond was mentioned but I
don't know what was said so
um but I was told uh got a year ago that
the plan was to go with a much younger
actor and he would be still in the Navy
he wouldn't actually be 007 and there
was going to be a Trilogy of films that
was going to build up to him becoming
007 and that's the point of Bonzer
origin story essentially An Origin story
basically so the idea being we've never
seen that
we've only ever seen him as double 07.
so if you want to do something different
we need to do that and it was going to
be like say these three films but
apparently Tom Holland was genuinely the
guy they wanted for about six months and
they approached him they but they talked
to him you know when he was all or I
might not come back for Spider-Man I
might not do any more
because he was
genuinely thinking he wanted to go do
Bond and I thought he was just trying to
get more money out of him
and well then they sort of went cold on
the idea and then he went straight back
to MGM I got more money than a Marvel so
I got more money uh so many
um but yeah so it worked out all lovely
but apparently that was the room that he
was genuinely thinking about it and the
two actors that they've spoken to
recently about Bond oral early 30s
they're both early 30s
that guy Edgerton what's his name
yeah he could be young Bond he already
he just confirmed that no he's yeah he
essentially alluded to like they've
already casted bun he said it's not me
and essentially they've already cast
Bond
he would be a good Bond though he was in
the running that's what I mean he was he
was in the last three or four names and
they got down to two names a couple of
months ago and I would be very surprised
if they haven't cast yeah I'm hoping
it's the guy from money train with the
uh Tash I love that yeah it's either
Aaron Taylor Johnson or like Richard
Madden right yeah those are the two yeah
that's it okay I want the Taylor Johnson
guy I think he's great I love her and
Taylor Johnson I just don't know if I
can see him as Bond Richard Madden just
feels more like that Bond kind of
Richard Madden that's the guy from The
Bodyguard yes bodyguarding Game of
Thrones yeah yeah right okay I could see
him doing it yeah I could see him he's
old though isn't he
yeah
he's he's like 32 I guess I don't know
36.26 yeah yeah I mean he doesn't look
36 but no he looks like he's late 20s
early 30s
you've got two types of bond though for
me right so you've got like a serious
Bond sort of like the Daniel Craig Bond
or you've got a slightly cheeky Bond
um a bit more you know like um uh the
guy after Sean Connery yeah
Roger Moore I I want us to see like a
slightly more Roger Moore character and
the tale at it and you can do a cheeky
version of bond that I think would be
more entertaining myself Madden would be
more of a serious Bond I think oh yeah
has just said is that just because of
Kingsman there and he's just very cheeky
in Kingsman
is that in the kingsman is he he's in
Kingsman Tara Edgerton he's the guy yeah
I'm sorry I missed that so yeah no
tanaged and I think time engine would
have done a good Bond but he's still in
the kingsman so I don't think I'd go for
that because it'd just be compared to
that over and over again no matter what
you do with Bond it would still be
compared to that somehow yeah they
wanted on his own page the exactly get
more Kingsman I'll be happy
a TV series
so we're getting it with Tara Edgerton
yeah
and then there will be another movie and
there'll be another King's Man movie as
well okay I like the king's man I
thought it was uh
I enjoyed it
um just go with the bond thing
um apparently
um Alec Edgerton was up for it but they
didn't like him because of the
connection with the kingsman and they
the executives wanted running Jean page
and Amazon but then running Sean Page
signed up to do the saint
thought he was going to get to do bonds
and the executives were like yeah we can
still do that and it was actually Amazon
and Jennifer sulky who stepped in and
went you can't do that
you can't have our main actor in our
main MGM project this is It's James Bond
you cannot have him doing a character
that's so similar you just can't
um
idiots what are you thinking sort of
thing and
but but that's why that's why they
couldn't do that and I think that's what
um why Edgerton didn't get as well to be
honest but
anyway
um
do you actually want to see a big we're
going to end in a second guys um in the
comments by the way if you have any
questions throw them in there I'm sorry
I've not been reading everything through
any questions from the previous throw
them in now
um started with Jay and then put like a
question and I'll notice it then I'll
keep an eye open for it but if you've
got any questions throw it in
but do you two want to see a big
Hollywood a-lister movie in this or do
you think actually it doesn't need it um
Keith Allen thank you so much for your
contribution it really helps the channel
really appreciate I don't think it
necessarily needs a massive name
good enough to carry the
carry the movie it doesn't need to be a
massive name because then there's a bit
there's an expectation I think
um
I think just get someone that's good
good and not not because they're
Tom Cruise or whatever
yeah just just have someone that's good
I mean I'm not opposed to the fact I'm
not opposed to having some a big name do
it if they if they're right for the role
but don't just hire someone because
they're a big name it's my point yeah
how about you guys
I think for for your your older cast I
guess for a Stargate movie that you
would need
not not big names but just consistent
great actors uh character actors
whatever it may be
but for whoever that new whether it be a
new team whether it be a a new
individual that we're kind of focusing
on if it's an individual I mean we keep
saying Mouse teller I feel like he'd
actually be great for it because he's
not
he's he's everybody knows him everybody
knows his face most people know his name
he's not the type of person that's gonna
like
over over bear you know he's not like
okay he's gonna come in here and just be
Miles Teller he's not coming in here to
just play himself he's he's gonna
envelop a role which would be nice uh
but I feel like you do need whether it's
just him or whether it's a team of three
four five whatever the new team is one
or two of them need to be at least Mouse
teller or Mouse teller sized names to
non-stargate people just excited about
something
they've got to put somebody on the
poster in there yeah yeah
you know you know I was thinking
genuinely today I was watching
um Carnival row
and um and I was watching Orlando Bloom
in the main role he plays the the Chief
Inspector uh and he is [__] good and
I was thinking he'd be perfect in this
obviously me I knew this was happening I
was thinking somebody like Orlando Bloom
he wants somebody that was maybe maybe
wants an a-lister maybe wants something
but maybe not so much now or somebody on
the miles tell us on the up
he might actually be difficult to get
hold of after Marvel after Maverick
um but but you want that somebody that
could do the movies and the streaming
series for me so you need you don't want
an a-lister you want like a c Lister
somebody you know their name
you know their face you're like oh I
like that thing he was in
but isn't necessarily going to be
expensive because we do not want anyone
that's going to be too expensive yeah we
want another Richard Dean Anderson
essentially yeah oh yeah but I think we
need somebody maybe a little bit if it
is Richard innocent yet coming off a big
thing the guy the guy who did the new uh
MacGyver get him to be the new Jack
Luger still it shouldn't either
what you want about I watched one
episode that I haven't turned it off
nobody's saying it because it would be
like some poetic thing
like both macgyvers announced I've not
watched it I've not watched it so I
can't come on I just I just went no
that's just crap I'm not watching I like
Lucas still but the MacGyver was awful
yeah it was not good right so we have
had Mark Ferncroft has thrown in a
question and it's more for you I think
Harris
so your opinion's idea of James Corden
Craig from Doctor Who we know James
Corden not as Craig from Doctor Who's as
everyone else other than that
um in Britain anyway
um casters Tom barbadill
um
do you know about that I didn't know
that I'd actually been decided
um oh he says on the idea of of yeah I I
could kind of see it I kind of know
where he's coming from but no I don't
like James Corden I see where you're
coming from but I just don't like James
Corden I don't want him anywhere near
anything Lord of the Rings Tolkien would
know one like he's already rolling over
in his grave
if that happens
we're gonna get a zombie Tolkien coming
out of the ground and it's I don't know
what's the apocalypse is going to start
somehow some way I no no you're the
promise James Corden is
he's very good at playing James Corden
he's not actually an actor I don't think
he's not a particularly good actor
he's always James Corden yeah into the
woods is the only thing I've seen him in
that was like all right that was decent
because he didn't have to like he's just
saying a little bit and did his thing
and that that was it cat
um
the best thing he was ever in is is
Governor Stacy that's the only good
thing he's ever been in that in my
opinion Smithy is the character Smithy I
love him
he's one of my favorite characters
because Smitty is James Corden that's
what I mean he's he's playing the he's
playing James Corden
who's Craig from Doctor Who these
smithy's 100 more likable than James
Corden though when James Corden was in
Doctor Who that was his name he had two
he was I was actually he likes him in
that to be fair
um but but yeah um he was all right are
you earning it for long
it was his baby that was in it for most
of us
I'm I'm okay with that as well
um
do you know you know
right now I'm sorry but you know who'd
be a better Tom Bombadil if you want
someone James Corden like but not really
like James Corden but that General that
can handle that Vibe and and things
Jack Black Jack Black is Tom Bombadil
you know how fun that would be yes you
can still have humor still have fun and
Tolkien would be like
instead of actually rolling over and
starting an apocalypse it'd be nice you
know and you can actually act yeah and
he could do the theme song
all of it
'd be perfect
we'll we'll call it an evening chaps
um so I do have one little bit of
business to do in a second but I didn't
admit but just to recap then so
um
because we have been asked by a couple
that have turned up late just to recap a
few of the details but you could just
rewind and watch the video from the
start
of course so we'll wake up quickly so on
Monday just gone a directive from
Jennifer salku's head of Amazon Studios
to Courtney Valentini who is the head of
Amazon film for streaming thing very
briefly said make a Stargate movie
we want this movie to be on our screens
on Cinemas by the winter of 2024 roughly
and for filming to begin late summer
Early Autumn and there is no production
team involved as yet
this is basically though the decision
getting made the decision we've been
begging for and that actually Mark
Fergus from penguin and Parker Who We
Believe will be producing this movie and
TV series and developing the franchise
as a whole has been begging Amazon for
so yes the decision has been made I can
tell you that I initially got this rumor
on Wednesday I filmed a video on
Thursday which aired on side track side
Saturday morning where I actually said
this rumor and I said I didn't believe
it was true
between filming however and um then
Aaron
um I was told by another person
completely independently that this room
was true they actually then told me that
it was going to be a hard reboot but
somebody else has said no it's not done
talk rubbish and
um I've been told since by two other
people one included for that actually
works for a major
um talent agency in Hollywood so if
someone's gonna know about this this
person would know I asked them they
asked round and they come back to me
within 24 hours and said yes it's true
he actually said yes yes are you smiling
yet was his actual response so and what
did it what else did you say Matt I
can't remember in his email now yes yes
are you smiling and then leave me alone
I've got the kids stop asking me stupid
questions I can't basically something
like I can't talk I've got the kids but
yes yes yes it's true are you smiling
yeah bearing in mind I had no idea what
any of this was about because Jay
wouldn't tell me and I read this email
and I'm like
what is true
so that is where we're at though chaps
and yeah it's it's it's exciting
um will we in Bob you've got a mental
mind your mind goes
it's beautiful but it's mental
um but yeah uh I just want to check his
number he's asked us any questions okay
no it's not been announced it will not
get announced for at least probably six
months Bonk Bonk I love it when you give
money just because I get to say Bonk
Bonk I'm pretty sure YouTube can't get
me in trouble for it uh this is actually
exciting to hear random thought I
actually thought Shane West could be an
interesting pick for a B list of
Stargate great actor let me remember who
Shane West is what you're saying West
Bene I'm useless for names
you're in League of Extraordinary
Gentlemen yeah yeah he's got mental eyes
this guy yeah yeah he's cool I like him
did he do is he the guy that did that
vampire thing a few years ago
Dracula 2000. he's my age
uh no we did a Dracula on um I'm trying
to remember if it's him or not yeah
Dracula 2000 in in the year 2000.
yeah it was good though I enjoyed it
um but thank you so much for the
contribution it really helps the channel
and uh I work I only work four days a
week there in my proper job so I can
concentrate on side track one day a week
and I was so happy Thursday
I did I did my first one
I did I filmed like five videos I just
went mental I was watching that video as
I was on as I was being sent home early
because of the snow and you're just out
there in your garden again it's it's
nice and snowy here
I'm getting on the bus
the British actor that did Lucifer again
whose names yes
all right I love him
that's Shane West guy the the Lucifer
dive that's kind of like the perfect
kind of person
to lead the team yeah he'd be great in
that and he's got that cheeky sort of he
can do the humor and stuff as well if
they bring that sort of back into which
which they've got to they can't do an
SGU
um Style Show they've got to do
something a bit of fun in it Shelley
sacked
damn it Shelly
as well so yeah Tom Ellis would be great
um howdy howdy Shelly
um right I just had a little quick
business so this week or last week we
started a patreon account
um and I've started putting I put most
of our videos I can't put all of the
videos on there first sorry guys like
Matt does his videos it would be we
could get them on there early but it
would be a bit awkward and um it's a bit
of a pain in the neck
um Kerry again thank you so much we love
you too
um quite new to our Channel Kerry and
she's probably one of the most
enthusiastic about the support
we love Kerry
um so um but I just wanted to thank the
guys that have joined up in the last
week or so so Shelley has joined up
thank you Shelley um you already do
enough for the channel but I still
appreciate it
um Dustin who has been yelling at me all
day well what's going on what's going on
when's the lifestyle come to Lifestyle
the life start the life start the life
start the life so Dustin
you'll find out I promise
um uh Dean short Stephen Lombard David
Boyce Harris you also already do enough
for the channel so you don't have to be
a patreon member but thank you so much
um
all joins the um patreon account this
week and they give a little bit everyone
and like I said I'll put most of our
videos on there early I will be doing
some little just for patreon videos
um now
um and um I'll do some fun stuff with
that once we get up um I do have quite
an exciting
um guest hopefully going to be joining
in couple of weeks
we will be very excited about it they do
know Stargate inside and out you will be
very happy about it I am going to ask
our patreon users to suggest questions
for that person so as soon as I sort of
done and I have a date and everything I
will put it on patreon only and you guys
will have the opportunity to suggest
questions for this guest
so
um there's a little treat for you but
I'm going to use patreon for that
because if you if you're going to give
me money to sit here and talk rubbish at
you the least I can do is try and give
something back
okay
not you Matt you're not allowed so um
you're not on the patreon it's weird
that why why aren't you a patron man
Jesus man step up what's wrong with him
uh three queers y'all say over there
I would be paying myself
oh yeah who doesn't want to pay
themselves
sounds dirty when you put it like that
working for yourself right like yeah you
would be paying mean money just to give
you straight back which would be
I've never had an employee before it's
great I'm gonna start thinking random
things to make you do
this week you have to wear a pink hat
on the live
I used to joke I used to a channel
agency about Mysteries and stuff I
needed to say we used to talk about
cults all the time I used to sat there
and joking that I really wanted my own
cult
well somebody got really angry and I was
just thinking I just wanted to come
around and do the tidying up and do my
housework and stuff and it's like it was
like the Church of Jamie in the Church
of Jamie the the thou shall do his
shopping
um but
I need a culture Thou shalt subscribe
subscribe and
hit the notification Bell and not the
notification Bell
um guys thank you so so much um it's
been a brilliant thing I love I've been
sitting on this for two days damn it
um I just love that I say don't get me
wrong stuff could still go wrong they
could still
anything happen now but the decisions
been made so
it's it's not it's not
the end of the beginning it's the
beginning of the end or whatever it is
we've had we've put I just feel like
we've had two years of a roller coaster
right and that roller coaster
is now
stopped you know it's a decision's been
made we're on the path now we've been
wandering around the woods whatever
metaphor you want we've been wandering
around aimlessly now we're actually on
the path and we're going in the right
direction they've made a decision
and I think in the next two to three
months we will get an official
announcement but they won't announce
anything until it's
they've got something to announce
basically an actor a production company
a script a blah blah blah
Amazon Ambassador tonight they never
announced anything until they absolutely
have to
um Shelly is either a bishop or the
Cardinal in the church Bishop of Jamie
no no she prefers stranger things like
she's um she's I I just borrow Shelley
oh that's nice there you go will they do
my ironing and washing things
I don't know I don't know go to work for
me
they just I just want to see all these
people in like white gowns turn up at my
job and they go who the hell are you but
we're here for Jamie there's no Jamie
isn't it no no we're here to do his work
for him we are Jamie we are Jamie
who are you Jamie but who are you Jamie
favorite here to do his work for him
um so that yeah that's gonna be the
thing um is this going to be the recast
right so I do I have so previously I was
told this was going to be an SG-1
Revival and you're dragging me backtrack
eight I was about to leave
and they would get as many actors from
the original series as possible
but it's not going to be
um like you know a Criminal Minds just
did it and they've had this criminalized
Evolution and it's all of the original
actors they've all just come back and
it's like the show never stopped and
they've just cracked on it's not going
to be that too much time has gone by
the way it was described to me was so
they made cherry pick actors from the
three franchises so we might get McKay
back we might get somebody else back we
might get and we definitely get McKay
back he's he's more than up for it yeah
yeah exactly
um we would probably get um General
Carter we would probably get Daniel
Jackson we would get these actors they
might come and go a little bit but we
would we would get them and they would
cherry pick from the three franchises
the the actors they really want that
works the story
um
but the new sg1 team will probably be
new actors they will probably be a new
team so we will have a core of a new
team with all of these actors we love
around them and then over time the other
actors might step back a little bit and
the new team would would increase
anything but
um
that's
what I was told was sort of the working
idea but as we say
who knows what might get decided now
that this new person is in charge and
they've been directed to do this they
might go a completely different
direction for Allina but let's see what
happens
um man united were playing today Mike
and we drew and casimiro got sent off
again
um you didn't lose seven nil again
no they didn't nil nil put Liverpool's
Liverpool
we at least only Drew so we didn't lose
so anyway but guys thank you so so much
really really great um for you to be
here and um have we got the adverts for
night Chevron still we do so let's run
the adverts and then we'll say bye-bye
nine chevrons.com
is your dedicated source for Stargate
news which will aim to complement this
YouTube channel with news that we have
from our contacts at MGM and Amazon
breaking news about a new potential
Stargate series as well as providing
reviews and any potential updates to
news stories that we break check out
some of the news articles that we have
already at nineshavrons.com
I will be writing um the full story
about everything we've been talking
today and that will be online Chevron so
the next couple of days we're also
running a um I'm doing a
the whole story from SGU ending to where
we are now in bit bits I've done the
first story it's on there we've also got
the possible tonight it's not live yet
hey well that's going up live today
because Matt's really slow apparently I
did that days ago
um
[Music]
but I'll get that story done and we'll
get that up as quick as we can
um
what else
um yes it really but so Star Trek also
has some amazing merch get yours today
and show your support at sidestrek.com
we also have a Discord server
.gg forward slash sidetrack s
I've not made a thing for that you've
got a couple member chats too
yeah and you can join the chat here or
you can join us at patreon and forward
slash Sidetrack and patreon.com
and we have the Facebook page and we
have everything else I will put links in
the video in a minute but I forgot to do
early because I'm an idiot
I'll put it in the chat thank you so so
much
um guys did you see the member chest
that people been sending in
no like the member it's like a it should
show up like a super chat but it's just
member chats for the members
oh I don't see that on my side oh yeah
yeah last one I came for was Carrie we
saw that yeah Kerry
they're chatting to each other Harris
you started chatting Keith Allen's uh
done five pounds I don't know if he said
thank you to him but thank you I said
that I did say thank you to Keith and
have fun so yeah we've done that yeah
anyway we're just we're just
talking now I can smell my Dinners Ready
so oh
someone's just joined the Discord let's
see who it is hello Beast or zero one
zero
you're lucky they didn't have as soon as
you said beast then I was very worried
that that was going to be a saucy name
um so you that could have gone anywhere
so you're very brave
um
that is now I've got to rename him on
the Discord the Beast big boy thank you
very much
recast mine as well
um but guys thank you so so much it's
really great um I'm sure we'll be
talking about this a bit more in the
next couple of weeks is I hope we will
try to find a bit more information and
we'll see where it's going but
it's a good news day we're happy happy
today
yeah my uh my friend what's wrong once
you hear my email go through because you
know I've had a bit of a bad back I I
got that email initially going through
that confirmed it and I always went yes
and she slipped on a stare and fell down
a little bit and then went
loudly
um I should come running up and then oh
she went you're right right guys look at
a stocking movie
you said I'm in pain too you know
because I thought you'd broken something
gotta love it we've been waiting for
this for so long it's just magic it's
just mad but guys like I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm going to end this stream
because we're just waffling now so even
though if I'm gonna waffle somebody
normally it's stormy actually
yeah yeah
like we started waffling at Jack Black
and Tom Bombadil you know it it happens
I really wants to question these things
happen you know right we will be back
next week I have no idea what for
because I'm not gonna say because then
something started getting up and we'll
just end up doing this again so
who knows but thank you so much guys
thanks everybody and things like guys
we've had great numbers tonight everyone
is joined us tonight thank you so so
much it really helps the channel and the
guys that have contributed as well
you're amazing
um go join patreon join the channel blah
blah blah see you next week
say bye everybody later
see ya
oh I forgot about doing the outro there
we go
[Music]